- [Narrator] If you look
at every U.S. recession,
well, since World War II,
you'll see two things always happen.
The GDP, the measure of
economic output goes down
and unemployment goes up.
- For most Americans, when
do you feel a recession?
It's when you start
worrying about your job.
- [Narrator] Now let's look at today.
The GDP is going down, even
the head of the federal reserve
says a recession is-
- Certainly a possibility.
- [Narrator] But the unemployment rate,
it's actually falling.
More people are getting
jobs, not losing them.
- We don't know if it's a recession.
What we can say is that if it is one,
it's not like anything
we've ever seen before.
- [Narrator] Here's why.
The reason the GDP and
unemployment are always together
is because they feed on each other.
When businesses layoff workers,
people spend less money
which means businesses make fewer profits
and lay off workers.
A recession can begin
at any of these points.
And in 2022, people could
cut back on spending.
Just look at consumer
sentiment, a measure that weighs
how people are feeling about the economy
and whether they plan to spend money soon.
Generally, when people
respond that they feel
more pessimistic, a recession follows.
And right now they're
feeling about as good
as during the great recession
in 2008, thanks to inflation,
not a great sign for the GDP.
- If people are frustrated
by high inflation,
if they think inflation is
gonna stick around for a while,
they might pull back convince
companies to cut back
and that leads to worse
outcomes for the economy.
- [Narrator] But businesses
are in a different place
than past recessions.
This chart shows the average
corporate profit margin.
In the past profits were
in these single digits
leading into several
recessions including 2001.
- That was a business driven
recession where companies
over-invested, they decided
they had to cut back
in order to rebuild our profit margins
and that led us right into a recession.
- The bubble has now burst.
I would not argue yet that
we've seen the bottom in NASDAQ
or in our tech index.
- So are we back in one of those cycles?
In some ways it doesn't look like that
because profit margins
are so high right now.
- [Narrator] Not only are
corporate profits in double digits
but the amount of cash they
have is close to $4 trillion.
Analysts say that's a
significant downturn buffer.
- They might just decide
they can weather this storm
and not lay off workers and
not cut back on investment
and kind of get us to the
other end of this adjustment
without a big retrenchment
that feeds on itself.
- [Narrator] And companies
have an incentive to not lose
any workers because many are
having problems finding workers
in the first place.
It's a really unique
time in the job market.
The labor force participation rate
is as low as it's been in 40 years.
And it isn't all due to the pandemic,
the rate has been
declining for a long time.
You can see it in the
unfilled job rates too.
As more people leave the labor force,
the more job positions become available.
Add in a pandemic and
that's a lot of jobs.
- 11 million jobs are out
there that they just can't find
people to fill.
Now to put that in perspective,
if you look back at say 2019
when the economy was considered
to be exceptionally strong,
unfilled job openings were seven million.
So like here we are talking
about a downturn in the economy
and we have four million more jobs open
than we had even at the
height of the last expansion.
So you have to ask yourself
a question, why is that?
Why is that happening?
One answer is that there's
generational change happening
in the economy.
We have millions of baby
boomers who are retiring.
So there's just not as
many workers out there.
It's also been the case that
there's just been really strong
demand for goods and services
in part because of all this
stimulus that was pumped
into the economy during the pandemic.
And so that combination of labor
shortages and strong demand
created this really robust job market.
- [Narrator] And it's
this robust job market
that can make a 2022 recession
if one develops so different.
After past recessions,
there was what was called
jobless recoveries where
GDP began to grow back
but companies continued
to lay off workers.
- [Jon] Right now we're
seeing a mirror image of that
where the economic output is contracting
and companies are still hiring.
It's what I'm calling a job full downturn.
- [Narrator] But how long
could an economic downturn
really be job full?
- This is unsustainable, right?
To have economic output contracting
at a time when companies are hiring.
So one of two things has to happen.
Either the economy adjusts
and companies start expanding again.
Or the economy keeps contracting,
economic output keeps
contracting and companies say,
whoa, we're over our skis
and we've gotta cut jobs.
One of those two things is gonna happen.
We just don't know which of the two.
- [Narrator] No recession has ever looked
exactly like another and if
there's a recession in 2022,
it won't look like anything
we've seen before either.
(soft upbeat music)